you go through life you don't sell your
soul you tell people the truth
uh you know and you get through it the
hardest thing to do
when we get involved my partners and i
can go into any company and in three
days tell you what's going on
[Music]
[Applause]
stephen gerstmann thank you so much for
joining in 20 minute leaders
my pleasure really really great to have
you you know with 51 years of experience
in in crisis management as an investor
angel investor as well and you know
really understanding how to maximize
the value of enterprises i'm so excited
to learn with you exactly what is crisis
management
and you know i'd love to spend the next
20 minutes getting to know you better
and and gaining some insight that
hopefully one day as a seasoned
entrepreneur
i will have to confront a lot of the
lessons that you've
er you've already learned so so let's
again who are you stephen
so let me give you a little brief
background my career started with the
ibm corporation
all right i was president of four
operating divisions of a company called
ital corporation in san francisco which
is in the computer and leasing business
in the 80s and 90s that was a hands-on
crisis
turn around ceo being dropped in by
equity or senior lenders
around what does that mean wait wait
stephen what does that mean
an interim ceo crisis turnaround
companies uh companies uh
let me turn it around companies uh
fail and companies succeed for different
reasons
right companies fail for three reasons
lack of control
preservation and forecasting of cash
preservation and forecasting of cash and
a lack of control
preservation and forecasting of cash
it's all about cash
it's all about taxes you have management
issues you can have market issues you
got gross margin issues you can have
competition
you can have fda issues doesn't matter
if you have enough cash
you can get through the process and
boards of directors or senior lenders
focus on
you know what happens in companies but
let me take it to 19 around the 2000s
and i'll talk about because i think this
is a thread here
when the internet blew up we observed
that there were no
hard assets there was intellectual
property
you had software you had medical device
you had life science you had mobile
you had fuel cell later on you had solar
so there was a whole new industry that
grew up where your normal m a process
really wasn't viable so we got involved
around 2000 with uh companies
that had anywhere between ten to two
hundred million dollars
invested okay and these companies again
something happened but it all revolved
around them out of cash
they were either senior lender companies
or they were venture private equity
companies
uh to the extent that what they needed
to do
uh was find a way to go forward so if
the board or
the bank decided not to continue to
invest which is all about cash
what happens then so you got to maximize
value in relationship
you know to the market so we created a
process called the date certain m
a process where we go to market
in six weeks we maximize the value of
the intellectual property and assets
we've done 109 deals 109
109 deals and you know to the extent
that um
we were able to you know to save jobs
save intellectual property that's not
steven i just want to i want to
just summarize to make sure that i
understood this correctly what you're
saying is if you have a company it's
it has investments of historically of 10
to 200 million
now they've reached a point where the
investors current or new are not
interested in continuing along the
company is now in a problem
because it's running out of cash it has
assets it has intellectual property
software value
it has value but but now you're coming
in and you're saying i want to help you
maximize this value i'm going to come in
for six weeks in and out
and i'm gonna maximize the value of the
assets you have and i'm gonna try to
save as much as i can
of the value of your company right i'm
gonna try to save as much as i can
for the value for the stakeholders for
the stakeholders stakeholders
are equity creditors senior lenders
investors all of the above employees
are employees stakeholders uh you know i
would call employee stakeholders
and you know when you go forward you
know part of the objective
is it's hard for investment banks to do
these type of deals because they get
into
what i call m a nirvana they get
interesting warranty
issues you can go on forever you get
letters of intent
and that is in the real world so we go
to customers competitors strategics vcs
for their portfolio companies senior
lenders
uh were branded worldwide we just did a
deal in israel
we've done a couple deals in china uh
australia obviously the u.s
and the message is the board has made a
strategic decision they want to go
forward
and try to monetize and maximize value
now why did the board do this
basically they have a fiduciary
responsibility to all those stakeholders
and creditors
right and to the extent part of the
challenge is
you know there has to be enough money in
the company to run a process
you know to pay us to pay the employees
to keep things going etcetera
what's happened over the years uh after
the debacle
you know seven to nine will
is that senior lenders who represent
probably about thirty percent of our
deals that they're involved in
made sure that they put covenants in
that there was enough cash to maintain
the operation to go forward
but basically the board has said i to i
want to decide what we do
uh you know to go forward we're not
going to put any more cash in
we don't want to do a hard shutdown we
want to meet our fiduciary
responsibilities
so we're an independent third party
that's able to go to the market
find out what's going on you know and we
basically send out a sales letter
all due diligence is done prior to the
bid date we send out an asset purchase
agreement we require a deposit
highest bid that conforms to the asset
purchase agreement wins
bids come in to me so it's a closed
process
we've changed the dynamics of power and
control
where the bank is sitting there
investment bank and you know
holding the company off to an loi or
whatever
one-on-one it's anybody can bid highest
bid wins and we can go back and handle
you know on price and all that stuff at
the end and the company can either
accept or reject the deal
now the perception of value is always in
the eyes of the beholder
right and value is the market the market
will determine value
because it isn't what people pay for it
it's what people
you know what it costs to get to the
next step so
you know as i said we've done 109 deals
very credible in that market etc
but let me give you some observations by
the way so just to make sure i
understand
when you come into the picture it is
understood by all parties that this
company is going to
be either merged or acquired is that
correct well
it is understood that we're going to do
an asset sale okay meaning the company
without its liabilities
meaning that the acquirer can decide
which people they want
uh in all cases the value of the ip and
assets or the company without its
liabilities
is really related to the quality and
availability of the key intellectual
capital
which are the people and it really isn't
the ceo
really isn't the cfo it's really the ip
technology people the people
really work in these areas that makes it
make sense the vp rnd
they those types of those roles are
really difficult when you
when you invest in a 200 million dollars
half of our
deals have been in the medical device
life science area all right
basically because they bring the most
return
and they can have a cd mark which is
approval of europe they can be in some
form of fda
you know etc but i want to take you to
one area that you sort of alluded to
when we talk about why companies fail
and why companies succeed in young
entrepreneurs
the biggest frustration and challenge
for myself and my partners or all ex
ceos
is that the board of directors doesn't
hold the ceo responsible and accountable
enough
all right i'm ready for this now yeah
all right so you have venture capital
you have senior lenders you have private
equity
a lot going on when things are going
well you're the ceo you're king of the
hill
if you haven't been through a down cycle
you don't know what to do
ceos will shut down they won't
communicate
we've been in situations where everybody
in the company knows what's going on but
the ceo is concerned about communicating
that
which is the worst thing you can do of
course you know it's all about
leadership motivation morale communicate
communicate communicate you tell people
the truth and it will free your soul but
make it a lot easier so you don't
anybody
how how often do ceos
not are not completely open with their
board how how many of the cases would
you well it isn't a matter of not being
open with the board
it's a matter of either the board not
forcing
issues sooner than later because they
see something's happening and they're
working on a leap of faith
or the ceo doesn't communicate but is
this a common thing
is this a common phenomenon i i would
say
you know what here's what's common
what's common is
at least 30 to 40 of companies that we
get into
the ceos have not been experienced
enough to know what to do
in other situations they've been through
it a couple of times you know in cases
it's a badge of honor if you
if you have a company that doesn't make
it because you know what's going on you
do the best you can
but the real issue comes down to when
you get in crisis mode
you need to communicate to your
employees to the creditors to your
stakeholders
to the senior lender to your vendors to
the market
okay and one of the issues that you find
if you are important to these people and
you're actually delivering product with
your intellectual property
it's hard for them to go away so you get
creditors to support you and they want
to see something happen
right so when we use the term maximize
the value of the intellectual property
and assets
we're trying to find a home that will
take it to the next level
now here's the waterfall the waterfall
is when we do a deal then we get paid
the lawyers get paid and management gets
paid
but the real people that come after that
are the secure
the secured creditors which is the
lender and then you've got the unsecured
creditors
which are the creditors the payables
equity really gets gets paid off in
these deals
but the real you know the issue that
you're doing is you're meeting your
fiduciary i use that word a number of
times
and you know if you can ask me about
three words i'm going to give you the
three words right now ethics integrity
and leadership
okay you go through life you don't sell
your soul you tell people the truth
uh you know and you get through it the
hardest thing to do
when we get involved my partners and i
can go into any company and in three
days tell you what's going on
and here's the profile if we sit down
and the ceo
doesn't let us talk or we have a meeting
with the cfo the cto the cmo
all the key executives and all the ceo
does is
tell us what's going on i know we got a
problem
because the strong ceo is going to say
cfo tell me what's happening
cto tell me what's happening cmo tell me
what's happening
and you try to work the problem in an
open environment
but again it's not necessarily it's
experience i mean
how old are you right now 24. god bless
you you're you're the future and you
give us hope
thank you very much you know run your
company at 27 but unless you've never
been through it that's what i want to
know steven so you know
now it's time for some selfish selfish
requests because i want some advice from
you i'm going to run a company i'm very
excited for that
i hope i get to a point where my company
is big enough and strong enough
and i and you know what i hope that
we're going to have to fight some
hurdles because i want to learn and i
want to experience
what what do i need to keep in mind from
day zero i don't want to reach a crisis
and then ask you stephen
what you need to do from day zero is the
following okay
one you cannot lead if you haven't done
go make a sales call call a vendor
go down to the manufactured plan meet
the people
understand how to communicate to
employees close an
order talk to the senior lender force
people into a discipline
because you you know it's all about
respect but you don't get respect until
you really know what's going on
the other thing is you know i told you
the three reasons why
companies fail start with putting in a
discipline of bottoms
up go forward cash flow not top down
you see all these great spreadsheets and
you know i look at them when i come in
too late i said doesn't mean anything to
me
i need to understand what we have as
cash in the bank
and on a weekly basis what i'm spending
why
and how and what creditors i can push
off or not because
i need to preserve control and forecast
cash
now you're a healthy company you just
got 10 million bucks okay you're feeling
good
your best business partner is your chief
financial officer
he or she you hold them responsible and
accountable
and you need to understand the numbers
many many years ago when i became a
division president of one of the groups
at itil corporation the ceo came in and
said this is before we had real
spreadsheets
i want you to run your business model
with your hand
so you know everything that's going on
calling
employees costs production costs cost of
goods sold market
you know you need to know the numbers
so it goes back to the fact if you want
to lead
you have to do and if you don't do you
can't lead
so understand your business the other
thing is
it's all about leadership motivation and
morale and how you communicate to people
you're in the business of you may want
to be liked but you need to be respected
right okay and people will respect you
if you tell them the truth
if you tell them what's going on if you
set reasonable goals
okay the other thing is is you need to
learn how to sell
up meaning if i'm the vp of finance or
marketing i'm going to sell up to you
about what's going on i want to i want
to anticipate
what's happening right you need to
manage your board
because your board may not be managing
you because they got 10 other deals
going on
right right okay so the first time you
get a glitch
i need help takes a strong person to say
i need help
what do i do what do you think nobody's
going to question your ability i mean
after the third time you do it i may
fire you but the first and second time
i'm going to give you enough room
sure sure so i mean it sounds to me that
i mean it all comes back and then to
integrity and honesty and and being
open and and being and allowing myself
to be to hold myself accountable but
also allowing others to hold me
accountable
but it sounds like unless you've gone
through these crisis is yourself it's
really really hard to empathize with
them and to really understand
because i can see the future you know
three years down the line i go to my
board meeting and you know something
doesn't work exactly like i think
a board meeting is an hour long we do it
once a month i'm gonna come in and i
have nine
other incredible things i want to say
that are just going to help me get my
next round of investments and going to
get me
you know the next uh and then the next
high five
it's it's gonna have it's gonna take a
lot of social a lot of personal
responsibility to get to
say that one thing that's not so nice
right
look i said it's about ethics integrity
and leadership
those are the three words you want me to
end with i'm beginning with it i'm in
the middle i'm going to end with those
same words i love it
it's your responsibility to understand
how to sell and communicate
okay i love it yeah now because you're
the young entrepreneur
you're going to screw up a couple of
times you have to right but let me go
back to the fact
if you haven't done you can't lead so
you can't
if you don't know the financial numbers
or you don't know your gross margin or
you don't know the architecture for sale
or the lead time to sell leave time to
install leak time to
you know you could close the sale leave
time to get cash
what your ar is you know 30 days 45 days
what's going on in payables what's going
down on the manufacturing floor
you're in trouble all right so
in good times everybody's having a ball
okay
and i've lived through now 87 to 989
94 to 95 001 203 007 to 10
12 to 14. you know this is different
2020. why is this different why is this
different
because it's the magnitude where people
are frozen
and they don't know what to do meaning
i have five proposals out there right
now i get calls from banks and equity
and everybody has a leap of faith hope
that they shouldn't
you have to you know i've always learned
that we're the last ones in
and everybody has that hope uh and you
know you just play it out and you bleed
some more
this cycle is very emotional and you
know you sit here i
you know three months ago my partners
and i discussed
you know the travel business the
entertainment business the market coming
back
there's no way you know and we're now
two and a half months later everybody
thought it'd be great
no way it's going to happen it's going
to take a lot longer so
i encourage people to make the other
hard decisions now
right and i'll give you a different
example
example is uh you have a prohibitive
real estate lease
you're a company that's doing revenue
and you have and this is an actual
company has 50 million bucks in the bank
they're burning 10 million bucks a month
they aren't going to downsize
but they have a contingent liability of
a real estate lease
okay we've terminated and restructured
about 800 million dollars of these
problem real estate leases
800 million dollars wow what we tell
people to do is don't pay the rent
okay go to the landlord and say
hey we need some help here and to the
extent that when we do this stuff
um you know we got to work something out
the landlord is going to say
no pay the rent i'm going to have my
lawyer call you give you a default and
you're going to say
i'm not going to pay and that's going to
cause the landlord to do something
sports spending lending on lawyers
uh you know creating havoc etc and
you're going to sit there and say we got
to negotiate
now where we were in oh 406 this is the
same timeline and i'll tell you the
ultimate reason why you do this
is that it takes it took 18 months to
get before the courts then
uh basically the worse you are the more
leverage you have
so you do a contingent liability
liquidation analysis you show how bad it
is
and the worse you are you have more
leverage you're playing poker you play
the insolvency card
all a landlord would get in an
insolvency is 12 months or 15
of the lease they may have two to four
months of letter accredited deposit
you negotiate because the problem is
they don't want to wait that long
and you've got time on your side here
right now the reason why you've got to
do this and i've had a number of
companies who should be doing it now
is five months from now when you had
that leap of faith and you got to go and
raise another 20 million
you have this overhang on your balance
sheet and i'm going to say
i'm not going to give you 10 million
bucks when you got a 10 20 million
dollar
contingent liability out there exactly
so
you know little different twists but
it's all in the mental set
of how you run your business how you you
know expect things to happen and
you know what happens going forward it
sounds like more than anything you're
coming in and you've seen 109 of these
deals you have to come in with such
resilience
and you know confidence that because i
mean i i'm assuming also that
you know the the clients that are coming
to you they're not in their happy state
this is not a
fun thing to do that they're coming to
you to help to help it
when they're losing right so you're
you're sort of coming in as their savior
that's sort of like they're like this
messiah right now i won't say they're
saying
i'm coming in to maximize value
problem we fix it at a time okay at a
time of crisis you're not gonna call me
and see
if you call me as a ceo i you know i
take your call i listen etc
but the only way you're gonna get to me
is the board told you to call me or the
bank told you to call me
all right and i'm going to have
credibility and you know and say okay
here's what the plan is
and we're hired guns we'll go in you got
to write a check to us like everybody
else
but we're the doctor on call right so
interesting analogy i had one of the
proposals out
is to a um i don't know it's about 80
million dollars invested in a
cancer development drug which is looking
real good and they're out of money
so um the uh one of the
board members is a very high profile
surgeon
so he says to me well steve you know do
this on a contingency we'll help you out
and you know you make more in the back
end
i said no look i didn't create it we're
gonna fix it
i'm the doctor on call yes if i go to
you and say
i'm gonna or you go to me and say okay
steve uh you know uh
we're gonna do some cancer surgery and
i'm gonna say okay i only wanna do
something and pay you if you would do a
good job
you know whatever so we like the lawyers
and the other higher guns are cost of
doing business of course so our job is
to make sure we get the best value
move on and what happens in these cases
is that the creditors are
able to at least go through and
hopefully work with the new company
the customers that are there will be
able to maintain a flow that's in their
system
so and that's what we do very very very
very cool i mean just a whole different
world that i had no idea even existed
and and i mean i i'm sure that
you know you have 109 different stories
you shared a few here but
i like you the ones you showed you have
109 more that we didn't get to hear
steven i need three words that best
describe you i already know what they
are but i want to hear it one more time
ethics integrity and leadership
i love it stephen thank you for the
inspiration to daraba and
have a wonderful day okay thank you